あっ道銀をちょっといいあっ山本さん御恵みはあんまり時間がなくてよかった
道元って翻訳が得意だった米や正式なものは英会話スクールのポスターぐらいしか行っ
たことがな実は俺のいとこが急に翻訳の仕事を頼まれたんだけどさ
それにいまぼく仕事で忙しいと言うより今の会社に入ったのはもうこういう
個人的な本屋5全く英語ができなくて僕も英語だいぶを忘れてるしそれで同件に助けて
もらえないかなと思ってサーフなんかごめんね他にお願いできる人がいなくてや
助けてあげられないの足並みに締め切りが来週の火曜日なんだよ土から忙しいて言っ
てるんだけどめっちゃ短いからこれ
2ページしかないんだにページ文の理由
タービン復水器って何ごめん言うの忘れてた
いとこが結城浩多く技術開発の会社に勤めるっていう気候区大丈夫大丈夫
中学時代に使ってた電子辞書かすかいやそういう問題じゃな俺に紅いもタルトあげる
からさ
田中さんのお土産ならもう貰ってるよの良い肌
今回だけでいいからやや
らないって言ってるか一生のながら嫌韓でしてくれないっぱい釣っ化し佐野沸騰くださ
こういうのを毎日のようにた生まれているんだそれでなくても残業してるっていうのに
さんごめん聞く前にもうちょっと考えそれにみんな言うんだよ
ごめんね他にお願いできる人がいなくて去ってそういえばこっちがことからないだろう
と思ってさんそういうつもりで言ったわけじゃないけどな
教えてくれない君のに特化学生時代に英語の授業を寝ていたからって何で俺がその人も
仕事をやらなきゃいけないの
八尾南で滅多にない休みを赤の他人のために好きでもない仕事をして過ごさなきゃいけ
ないので気
いる人にはやる義務があるそういうことだったらこれ最近腰悪いからトイレの掃除あっ
てくれよ
ついでに洗濯もよろしくないたいならやってもいいけどいい
たとえこれが山本その仕事だったとしても俺やらないからね
いくらなんでもちょっとしたしすぎないごめん悪かったよ本当にちなみにこういう時
親しいであってるあっつ
魂だねそうだ厚かましいだペンネいつも直してもらって
いつでもどうぞ
ni